[Musique]
dans le jardin public tout ensoleillé un
petit moineau sur l'herbe est tombé un
gosse soyons ou sur l'oiseau se jette
mais une brave dame d'un geste au lard
et que fais-tu gamins restent donc de
partir ça t'amuse donc bien dans le
faire souffrir
bravement au petit mais hommes selon le
cityval ça
[Musique]
e
où
paris et circle et de colline d'où il se
laisse découvrir d'anciens villages ils
sont perchés devenus des quartiers de la
capitale depuis un siècle seulement et
restant malgré cela des villages dans la
ville
[Musique]
sans doute quelques mystérieuse épidémie
en chasse aujourd'hui les habitants ont
murs les portes et les fenêtres les cool
les couloirs sont déserts je sais
pourtant que long de ces rues derrière
ces façades depuis des générations
des milliers et des milliers de destins
se sont croisés
chacun a son histoire le plus souvent
perdus à jamais chacun est une parcelle
de l'histoire des voix nous parle de
souvenirs quelque part persiste la
mémoire un papa est né en 1827
alors il a fait cette commune entre 70
et alors doit pas un dû son salut qu'à
un versaillais qui l'a arrêté et puis
nous emmener ils étaient plusieurs si
les ont emmenés à ce qui les ont sorties
n'en appellent plus très bien si c'est
du côté d'arles grange aux belles qu'ils
ont sorti dans tout les égouts
ce que quand ils sont se sent lui aussi
fusillé au père lachaise
ils ont descendu dans les égouts ils
sont sauvés par les est beau alors là en
sortant je peux pas vous dire si c'est
au grand jour belle mousse m'en rappelle
plus je vais peut-être entendu raconter
mais je ne sais pas et alors ils ont
sorti là il a trouvé diversifié qui les
ont arrêtés il y en a un qui est passé
lui dit quel âge as-tu rédigé quarante
trois ans 45 ans alors il dit tu as tu
es marié des oui j'ai une famille ma
femme et mes filles qu'il avait
plusieurs filles alors il a dit et bien
à ce moment-là il a dit j'ai ton
revolver ces termes et jette ton arme
quelque part ça passera c'est ce qui
fait qu'il a été sauvé parce que comme
il avait pâti pris les armes à la main
il n'a pas été fusillé tandis que tous
ceux qui étaient avec tapas qui les ont
emmenés à brest ils ont fusillés ou été
la première femme un papa bruno zain est
bien derrière chez elle on fume juillet
tout ce qu'ont avancé
c'est à dire que par exemple quelqu'un
veille
gens s'affairent les allécher de
commissaires et déclaré qu'ils étaient
contrôlés marseillais enfin édicte en
exceptant commune à ça y était on
l'attrapé et où on allait surveiller la
un homme comme ya un acteur qui avaient
été fusillés comme ça qu'ils n'avaient
rien fait d'arrêter bout d'un malade et
puis on a empoigné parce que qu'un
épicier qui ont roulé puis il a fait
publier et il y avait beaucoup beaucoup
il ya eu beaucoup de gens comme ça
et alors quand ils voulaient monter un
arbre ils étaient forcés de monter des
barricades il s'est efforcé mettant un
arrêt à chaque fois qu'ils passaient
devant une barricade autrement les
laisse pas en paix avec tous ceux qui
étaient dans la rue les comparer pour
lancer les barricades et alors ma mère
elle restait contre 42 en belgique avec
un mec comme un grand gars sont allés
commentary propre et était elle avait 13
ans
alors ils vivaient dans les caves et
elle pourrait avoir ce récent avec une
poule on se sent bras et du montage et
la poule a est porteur puisque elle nous
a raconté c'est que en face il y avait
un boulanger et elle a vu je suis gay
vingt personnes devant être le meilleur
vin quand on était tout gosse tout
simplement
ouais on allait toujours sur le fond du
problème dupuis du perp hôpitaux ferait
son grand père se faire surprendre au
moins et ben nous faisait voir des
machins mais devant devant la statue
tiers
c'était son nom mire des proches me
remets 30 points devant la statue a dit
inquiet qui actuelle cliquez là comme
une fois
non
si loin de nous si près de nous c'est
belleville vers 1900 une sorte de
campagne dont aujourd'hui encore on
découvre des traces
c'était encore la campagne comme la
comme la campagne les gens avaient
encore leurs rangs des grands jardins
chez nous là nous avons invité lors du
pré saint gervais nous avions deux un
pavillon devant un grand jardin les
votes d'agrément derrière une courbe
nous avions des lapins des poules et
mais nous avons vu des cas des canards
et des dans le fond de la propriété de
la maison le laver un grand jardin où
mon père zeus et ses légumes
vettel devait être arrivé lui être
cultivée à tort aussi même s'il allait
faire ses légumes
nous nous aimions presse amélie la messe
a les mêmes trouver un truc qu'il avait
acheté 4 arrosoir et mon frère et moi
nous courions à la pompe l'eau ambitions
les arrosoirs effet d'après l'élu a
porté lui il bougeait pas du terrain et
c'est nous et c'est lui qui arrosait
nounou cavaillon chercher l'eau à la
pompe
il y avait une une grande année il y
allait jusqu'à la rue des alouettes qui
maintenant est la rue coeur de ces
essais talent et il y avait des grands
certes son enfer et de la vigne qui
montait de chaque côté
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lavigne était au propriétaire mais c'est
les locataires qui en avait la
jouissance est cultivé mais c'est de la
roupie de la ville et au moment des
vendanges tout ce qu'ils pouvaient
vendanger depuis leur jardin et c'est
tant mieux et autrement le point tout ça
c'était déjà renard yam et rien d'autre
si les tango ce qu'on allait voler des
raisons vraiment j'ai toujours tous
s'étaient pas mûres dans sept à
verrières settings à risque avec des
gosses
il me rappelle j'avais les cinq ans et
demi j'avais tous mes frères avaient
trois qui allaient rue de la mare
l'école drôle la main j'allais
l'emporter le pain quand la boulangère
nous apprend peut-être pas chez moi
qu'aller leur portée le pain pour manger
le midi
des fois la boulangère a eu un petit peu
en retard alors ce canal est j'ai du
monde cadel comme emma les palais comme
palander n'est déjà pour commencer à
manger on jouait sont tous espèrent des
bicyclettes en bois larouche les rues au
delà mouzaïa les champions des
bicyclettes en bois société c'était le
grand jeu des des gosses du quartier ya
pas de patin à roulettes à ce moment là
on connaissait pour ça ou les gens
n'aiment pas les moyens de payer à leurs
enfants
alors on choisir nous mêmes des
bicyclettes en voit ce qu'on allait
c'est aux musulmans
et puis on allait à gavroche là dans la
rue des alouettes et un gavroche
du reste c'est toujours marqué sur le
sur la boutique alors ils nous faisaient
des pièces de terre pour deux sous pour
de souvent donné de souper on rentrait
alors on des fois on acheter un sou le
moment parce que c'était une boutique
qui avec le gavroche mais il y avait des
bombes on est loin des moments des
journaux alors pour 3 souvent n'allaient
tout l'est toute la journée du dimanche
vers une pièce de théâtre ou faisait
trois actes et alors notre existence
notre plaisir c'était d'aller manger sur
l'effort en famille
alors les filles allaient avec des
petites bricoles pour jouer mais les
garçons c'était les chairs volant et il
y en avait
fifi cas dans le xxème conventionnement
10 où j'avais 12 ans que j'ai commencé à
travailler tous entrés ce moment là on
commence cette bonne heure nous on était
quatre si on devait partir
on a commencé de travailler 13 ans eric
comment 1,13 encore parce que mon père
de la série mais beaucoup commençaient
dès les autres commencé plus tôt eric
commencé à 12 ans et même à roujan s'il
avait eu le retrait des dj loin de
travailler en jouant mon temps on
n'était pas riche quand on avait besoin
d'emprunter france voisine ont relu
empruntait la fois d'après ses pairs
l'aude voisine qui en avaient besoin
ça sent passer comme ce conseil est
comme ça si moi je ma mère a travaillé
beaucoup parce que ma mère était pas en
trente ans leur âge les gosses du voisin
dit à la presse et aux incidences un
jour mon père il devait le terme aux
propriétaires en a vécu ce nerf il y
avait cherché meubles
lorsque je me souviens des de cette
affaire c'est ce qui m'avait frappé
c'est que mon père les avait cachés ni
suspense qu'un pétrole dans leurs murs
et touché je me rappelle de ce qu'est le
concierge qui était un ancien gendarme
lui a veillé sur le volet voulait sortir
aux meubles
mon père est la production de ce fait
ils ceux qui ne travaillait pas et avait
n'avait aucun secours il fallait pas en
écho mais il y avait beaucoup de métier
qui travaillait six 6 mois sept mois et
puis qu'ils travaillaient pas le restant
de l'hiver ça valait rien demandé
c'était comme les familles nombreuses il
n'avait pas de secours et une famille
nombreuse jamais un monsieur qui avait
sept enfants sa femme était morte bon
lui de naissance ou bosson pétrole d'un
mois on était dans une manche à redon ce
processus n'est une petite manchette de
rien du tout avec une lucarne sur le
doigt chez touchent le rsa majoration
est un jour que je devais être malade
ma mère était par délivrer son ouvrage
alors j'ai produit étant tout petits dès
3 ans alors il a eu toutes les souris et
qu'elle valait partout sur les murs je
lui ai fait partout à 4h30
boulanger alors va chercher le pain de
pain café alors les croit son équipe un
peu ça qui avait produit la veille
s'était imposé alors elle même était
sous forte pression n'aime pas de gosses
n'ont pas encore le poids du tri city la
mère se met hors d'elle est lui même pas
pour faire le café de l'orme et et son
fou voyez c'était frais directs sa
couenne et ses 18 h à fond mais y avait
des grèves formidable il eu des autobus
les omnibus plutôt qu'ils étaient
retournés dans le faubourg du temple est
haute mais je vous assure que ça bardait
un petit peu puis chambre au clair il
dégainait dans le faubourg dans le temps
il y avait un mouvement de grève on
soutenait les grévistes
ici à mon château sur le boulevard il y
avait une grève demain au moment des
grèves des grèves ici venez chercher des
vivres pour la journée ont ordonné à un
poteau peu où les gentils qu il pouvait
passer la journée à l'est alors c'est un
pour tous tous - fournit ici et ailleurs
[Musique]
belleville c'est un peu la montagne pour
ceux qui n'ont pas le courage de faire
l'ascension à pied a été construit un
funiculaire
il est vrai qu'on ne le prend pas trop
au sérieux ça n'est pas tout à fait un
vrai moyen de transport aux heures de
pointe on s'y retrouve on s'y entassent
non sans plaisir
jenny cullers oui j'ai pas vu j'ai pour
reconstruire mais souvent l'outil dirait
que les gens travailler très tard le
soir
mais quand il fallait que quand
j'arrivais plage à leur public avec eux
pourquoi funiculaire pour monter lui
j'avais lui rabâcher les consignes
claires le projet pour au début où je
veux les payer un sou c'était dessous et
lorsqu'ils savent très bien à faire
c'était un triporteur parce qu'il
confesse que les grandes tiges peut
faire avec un crochet et s'accrocher
face au au cul du funiculaire et en pays
d'olmes est formel j'étais cet échec
quelque chose comme montmartre est fier
son funiculaire est venu nous étaient
fiers de leur fille titulaire mais
comment une locomotion cette époque
c'était j'étais vaut pour les mots pour
les personnes d'un certain âge sûr on
allait plus vite à pied en descendant
ils nous battaient un tout petit port
montant mais redescend dans l'année plus
vite sur le funiculaire
alors les gens montés à pied saleh à la
retenue c'est une rue grouillante une
rue très passante mais alors en
descendant la rue de belleville nous
trouvons la maison schaub runner qui
louait les chars à banc parce qu'il y
avait des chars à bancs dans ce temps là
et en fâcher show braun r il y avait une
vacherie
je me rappelle quand on mangeait des
petits pois à la maison j'allais porter
les coques des petits pop pour avoir un
verre de lait il y avait également une
vacherie rue générant alors nous
redescendons prébendes
alors nous trouvons le terreau de
belleville où naturellement on vasella
portes demain la tour de nesle les
mystères de farid incendie sans tarder à
minuit et d'avoir commencé à 7 heures
alors tout le monde était là qui
faisaient la queue et à droite du terme
de belleville il y avait un petit café
qui s'appelait les eaux durant alors là
il cherchait des sans abri de protection
à trois sous le froid et tout le monde
commençait à la queue à mort dans les
sandwiches et puis ça finissait l'inter
est ce qu'il y avait de plus jeunes gens
là haut c'est qu'avec le poulailler
alors quand il y avait un traître il
jouait dans la salle tout le monde
criait attention attention il est
derrière la porte et pierre izard
ah bah non le prêt qu'il en prenait pour
son peuple et charlie chan
le jeune premier s'appelait bay heureux
j'ai jamais vu balancer de coussa mais
des pommes et puis des hommes pas des
tomates y en avait pas mais des pommes
et puis d eux ça j'ai vu surtout sur les
acteurs ce qui était et qui était
méchant passé comme dans les deux gosses
alors là débat mais c'était plutôt soir
nous dans la journée de dimanche étaient
des gens comme presque des jours
tranquilles connaît les ouvriers mais
tranquille des ouvriers tranquille
pourtant belleville c'est bien qu'il
fait peur à beaucoup
ce passage a été baptisé des faucheurs
et la fauche dont il s'agit n'a rien à
voir avec les pacifiques travaux de
l'été le défi soir des propos mal famés
qu'ailleurs
pourquoi il a été plus mal famé
et à tous les quartiers sont mal famé et
ici c'était comme partout et apporte
plus de bandits qu'ailleurs vous avez
tous les freins comme on disait à ce
moment là les frappes les malfrats que
les apaches avec leurs casquettes leur
machin là on en reste avec le machin
comme ça dans le bol chez moi la
personne mais en face chez moi où
j'habite il ya même un espèce de bar on
appelait au pis en des homardiers oki
sander il ay les rams avaient un parent
de drones de type avec des rouflaquettes
et casquettes interrogé sur le côté et
dans la nuit ça se met tout le temps
même dans deux jours je vais souvent des
bagarres souvent se voir mais se
battaient à coups de couteau nous en a
d'ailleurs qui se battait avec la rue
n'est pas très large
ils se battaient alors défaut pour
recevoir un coup de couteau
on avait joué oubliant tout d'un coup
viard est libre je m'amuse à lancer les
pays comme ça avec le doigt est
d'essayer de faire le point partenaires
se présente il me dit on fait une partie
aux vues si vous voulez une partie on
limite à 50 points
puis j'ai vu qu'il était bleu prennent
la porte ça m'a consolé ne le
connaissons pas disait il va être le
terreau payer la tournée et les prêts
j'étais au dessus de ça et rappelle plus
qu'il sait qu'à gagner c'est moi ou lui
enfin de 12.5 puis deux trois jours
après qu'un camarade kim 10 10 dont tu
t'appelles avec qui tu as joué au
billard maman oui tu le connais pas du
tout
c'était bruno bono et sa bande qui
répandait la terreur avec à belleville
pavillon avec jardin mal à bono est
bonne
c'était le principal puits y avait une
femme les autres je ne sais pas l'ombre
alors quand ils ont déménagé tout le
monde était content qu'ils aient des
ménages passe quelque chose sur une âme
et roosdaal sûrs alors tout l'espoir on
les voyait la nuit zekri veut toujours
c'est un acte qui faisait des passeports
ou les cartes de nom parce que les gens
n'avaient pas de nom ce qui menait il
est divorcé de se cacher alors il ya eu
des menaces de guerre et d'avouer ce
moment là tous les gens ont même
plusieurs fois par an ella bleu et rouge
au pré saint gervais ont manifesté
contre la guerre
la première fois que j'ai entendu causer
jean s
c'était une manifestation contre la loi
de trois ans et contre la guerre et
cette manifestation avait lieu sur la
butte du chaperon rouge qu'on appelait à
l'époque que ceux qui se situait sur les
fortifications entre la porte du poids
sans gervais la porte aux petits as dû
aux gens c'était un bon copain
vous l'avez que du jeu peut dire
personnellement je les ai connus comme
ça dans les réunions
il était très sympathique serrer la main
à tout le monde tutoyant tout le monde
et quand il parlait tout le monde
l'écouté et il avait une façon de
s'exprimer
c'est comme si on lisait dans un livre
qui était souvent quand il faisait les
dix coureurs aux fortifications du sein
par le même gars et ben quand on part
fait un
il disait bien la police laissez le
partir tranquillement mais j'ai vu une
fois arrivés au bout de leur damer louis
ils ont ouvert les battements de l'école
et tous les gens sont sensibles à north
appelle d'abord alors là je suis pour
rester moins survoltée de malheureux
belles villas sont moins alors les y
avait trente et unième qui était caserne
au retour elle il descendait tous les
samedis mais ses comptes est que cette
fois l'islam est la vigie regard de la
musique pour tanger faire mousser les
gens avaient pour qui la neige près un
peu guerrier alors les gens du quartier
de belleville ménilmontant étaient pas
contents ils manifester pourquoi les
soldats mais contre cette façon des
brûlures ou c ou patriotisme je faisais
mon cri avant l'heure mais et un breguet
alors j'étais défendu j'en avais crier
vive la guerre on aurait été un bloody
mais on gagne on voit d'ailleurs enrichi
d'un seconde épouse mettra guide est
emballé par la police unsa et vu ce
qu'établit gélas à la poste et war
mobilisation générale
moi je vais voir je regarde mon
s'intitule le cinquième jour aux du jeu
ce temps et un jour éléments du
pommes de terre plus cher c'était 12 3
où j'étais ravi j'étais parti moi
j'avais jamais des soldats et ma foi
les gens ont envahi la boutique ils ont
sorti sous les mains de la maison de
l'épicerie on les a retrouvés six mois
après et puis ont mis le feu dans la
boutique parce qu'il vendait les pats
matière trop cher et puis il en sortit
damon devrait ans avait comme ces grands
éléments du rire des anglais en minimes
autant j'ai en effet d'autres qu'il est
monté chaise ballack avant ça se passait
les jantes et dirige les services que ce
parfum est passé par ces tarés culte est
une machine allemand que c'était une
société allemande avant tout les dépôts
mazion tous été saccagés dans alors ou
matin dans des camps sont gays
selon le matin puis un décor magique
debout alors nous comment être en figaro
francis en était aux premières loges
pendant la guerre de 14 il y avait un il
avait installé un espèce de postes de
décès à si on peut être les sachets pas
si à l'époque on appelait cela sur le
belvédère des buttes chaumont
alors il avait mis des gens de 75
coéquipiers enfin qui essayait de tirer
en l'air
alors quand tu es avion passait tout le
monde descendent et au métro ils
chaumont cela n'allait pas changer grand
chose avec la bac a peur avec la guerre
de 40 alors il ya évidemment les
pompiers qui pensaient pour annoncer la
l'erp avec une sirène sur la voiture
quitter elle qui a lancé la fin de
l'année ebikon c'est tomber les dunes
alors on était bien tranquille tous les
goûts j'avais un petit chien ce moment
là qu'on m'avait donné parce que mon
fils joue d'un chien alors tout d'un
coup on entende on savait monde alors on
a tout le monde on s'est regardé tout en
l'air on ne regarde plus rire la lys et
pour nous puis alors après un frein très
souvent table là ma nièce qui avait 13
ans s'est jeté dans les bras de mon fils
c'est arrivé le ch est arrivé j'ai
écouté laissez moi je vais aller voir si
on brûle fort parce que moi je veux pas
brûler alors j'étais là parce qu'on
savait pas que nous ayons fait qu'ils
allaient tous fermés les négos double
rideau parce que falek tous fait noir
alors j'étais dans la cuisine
gêné faire innovant et puis ça brûlait
de la vente partout de tous les côtés
somme folle et on savait pas ce que
c'était le premier jour la verte âge ça
pourrait tous les 20 minutes
et qu'est l'or
la deuxième fois il y en a un qui est
tombée amoureuse la patronne était dans
sa quête elle avait une fausse perruque
et sa perruque été remporté par la
déclaration puisque les grâces tout on
était passé et alors après quand tout le
monde est revenue de ses émotions ont
cherché le canard à la paix entre
comprenez on n'avait retrouvé que les
cheveux et ça fait le cadre des cheveux
alors que c'était simplement pensé elle
va passer vu son père eut cavaliere ne
s'est pas fait boire mais le plus triste
c'est qu'il y avait un pauvre soldat qui
est en train d'acheter une marchande de
quatre saisons et lui il a été projeté à
une personne du premier étage de cette
étude et à la femme qui était carrément
tout logement là de travailler au métro
et sept femmes allaitant femme se
reposer les yeux ou à un gros chèque à
persiennes serait pareil toujours restée
folle ben quand on est un métier tracy
retravailler dans une maison ils avaient
travaillé avant de partir aux soldats en
poste de la région la maison n'existe
puis sont morts tous les deux patrons
est mort la patronne est mort tout est
mort je finissais rester trois ou quatre
ans en plusieurs points
je m'en allais je revenais c'est un peu
le pigeon voyageur
j'étais une maison fait pour moi partie
ou aux bas salaires à droite à gauche
j'étais un moment donné j'allais à
rambouillet je vais à leurs messages des
autres fourmis pour l'élevage des petits
présents ramasser les autres vies
tamisée et je venais les revendre au
château ont élevé les petits présents et
les autres poules faisanes gérard manset
emile a racheté au château m'étais
retrouvé sous des poules de cayenne et
vous à l'élevage devriez plus que
je voyais bien mais alors c'est cette
époque de l'année
ces saisonniers en clientèle ont été
variées à la finition les heures les
après midi c'était des gens charmants
qui venait écouter les classiques n'est
ce pas dans le calme et le soir c'était
toute la genèse qui déversait justement
des tous les ateliers qu'il y a dans la
rue de belleville allons nous étions
l'ancien palais du travail qui était un
long couloir il y avait des arcades et
un petit espace aux très petits je me
rappelle il y avait un tapis de cordes
il y avait même une grosse canalisation
qui passe est souvent les clients but
est d'en c'est très amusant sallèles et
les retenir de cette journée lectrices
heure où des gens voulaient essayer
d'acquérir la force puisque les docteurs
leur avait préconisé cette chose-là le
revenu au moment de calme et puis alors
le soir nous avions les jeunes chantent
ils venaient écouter tous vous les airs
trépidant le jans commencé à apprendre
l'extension est déjà spartoo cherche pas
pas et nous avions justement des disques
les premiers par une ou les avions 1925
pour les bellevillois c'est toujours la
bonne saison de l'amitié pourtant comme
s'ils ont serré où chacun se connaît
l'inconfort et la vieillesse des maisons
étaient des maladies chroniques on parle
depuis toujours de démolir et quand nous
sommes venus la propriétaire ne voulait
pas ni eau ni gaz ni électricité parce
que ça allait être démoli la 33 ans
à 33 ans alors voyez vous on est
toujours là et on attend et comment elle
fait ses preuves mais elle était très
calme il n'y avait pas de voiture la
mousse le plantain poucet entre les pas
belle et c'était c'était un quartier
vraiment tranquille alors je dis le
dimanche les maris jouer à la belote
chez monsieur abrial et
on allait boire l'apéritif le soir on
était une bande de copains alors disais
qu'est ce que tu manges toi moi j'ai ça
ben moi j'ai de ça je suis ceci et on
descendait tout cela on buvait
l'apéritif on mangeait chacun descendez
ce qu'il avait on mangeait tout son
copain et alors on chante et on danse
est même en avance et même l'autre côté
ce moment là c'était mieux organisés
comme la wii oblige à y chanter dans la
rue puis danser dans la rue tandis que
mana il n'y a rien du tout maintenant
c'était dix fois mieux dix fois mieux
que mel large volet on veut y en a qui
travaillent et à l'extérieur il y en a
un qui demeurait dans la maison ils
étaient et gauthier un autre était
plombier un autre était balayeur les ja
il descendait le soir il descendait avec
leurs chaises ils se mettaient la lune
et chercher une bouteille de bière ou
une bouteille de vin suisse et a plus ce
n'est pas ce qu'ils voulaient boire et
il se mettait là y causer jusqu'à 12 eur
puis à 10 heures pour le mal gagne et
d'aller se coucher
et si on m'avait dit que oui c'était la
petite tape ice est elle applicable
m
rien d amour pour cible hier l'après
midi que le soir à la sortie du travail
surtout c'était weser ça quand il y
avait le 22 mars qui était tout content
ma porte
bien bien souvent le soir et le
l'éteignez la courte échelle pour être
le bec de gaz pour mieux se bécoter mais
ma pauvre mère qui avait à ce moment là
soixante dix huit ans quand j'avais dit
qu'il y avait des amoureux ne dit c'est
pas possible c'est pas possible un jour
qu'elle était là julie manet à vado
warta sg ouvert le rideau il y à
regarder cela était un genre en train de
s'expliquer là et elle est à rigoler
parce que c'est 67 ans pour la faire
démarrer du carreau du quartier quoi
dans ce temps là il y avait sa grâce
ballerines beiges à la cour son goût
existe encore je conduis le dimanche
sans faute elle conçoit sa honte à nous
ou à un agent via les pensions parce que
c'était peut-être aurai-je prononcer
trop hachée non mais vous lanciez déjà
la wii alors la jav a annoncé le musée
tout puisqu'elle musette est chouette
oui je vais pas le moderne parce que tu
faisais des l'apprécier savent pas
danser c'est vrai bricoler j'ai dû
trouver des brumes dans ce bel élan
n'importe quoi la patronne qu'elle a
jardin démarche n'importe quel boss qui
principalement les to be
[Musique]
comment pouvait-il faire bon vivre dans
ce décor à quatre sous peut-être parce
que beaucoup étaient de ce vieux parilla
de père en fils est ici dans les
passagers dans les cours se sont noués
des amitiés dès l'enfance on s'est élevé
ensemble dans les rues
certaines rues ou inexplicablement on a
envie de se promener de se blottir sans
doute aussi la misère et les épreuves
supporter en commun qui donne le
sentiment d'être ensemble
être ensemble peut-être faut-il ce
sentiment là pour faire vraiment une
cité jacques est né ici
il a connu tout cela est aujourd'hui
dans ce qu'il faut bien appeler un
jardin il vendange sa vigne pour la
dernière fois
[Musique]
gallery
[Applaudissements]
segura la plante et avec henri la non
aller perdu l'aller perdu
ici doit nous mettions les effets et à
chaque fois il va on était obligé de
retirer parce que ça moisissait si tu
mettais pas tes chaussures 8 10 jours
dans les chaussures témoigner on avait
l'ouvragé précité
on avait ce qu'il fallait même si
c'était une 8c la pensée de capital
parce qu'elle était venue mais alors là
je réussis la langue parce que dans ce
coin je mettais ma machine à coude et
comme on n'a jamais je n'aurais jamais
lumière jamais soleil alors ça me permet
d'expliquer la machine à coudre sens aux
lettres c'est du soleil artificiel mais
de la table au genre
il m'a fallu me manger de la cuisine
c'est la cuisine
alors là tu avais livier à côté je
mettais ma cuisinière pour ce que je me
dis qu'avec litres ou qu'est ce qu'il ya
il fallait quatre tonnes de charbon dont
souffre et encore un autre
quant aux symboles il ya eu des avis en
car nous on avait vu des vieux de la
vieille dame en avril à eau
encore une fois vous rencontriez dans le
passage du foyer la cause et aux crosets
oui pour cause entre rhône et saône et
des acquisitions des problèmes chez les
uns chez les autres
l'article est celle ci
blanchet jacques ne sont pas les seuls à
quitter leur maison pour le vieux
belleville le temps des démolisseurs est
venue du sang trouve peu pour regretter
vraiment le logis en lui-même depuis
longtemps insalubrité non ça n'est pas
le tobi qu'on regrette même si on n'y a
passé une grande partie de sa vie
pour l'instant avant le bulldozer et la
pioche se développent un exode inégale
il ya ceux qui sont déjà partis
il ya ceux qui sont encore là et qui
savent quand ils vont partir à défaut le
savoir toujours où ils vont allaitent
il ya aussi ceux qui ne savent ni quand
ils partiront ni où ils zhiyong cela
évoque d'autant plus facilement le bon
vieux temps qui n'était peut-être pas
toujours aussi bon que ça et dont ils ne
veulent retenir aujourd'hui qu'est ce
qui faisait la vie en commun
[Musique]
j'ai fait l'épicerie gens c'est eto'o
les mêmes labeur les jeux le fromage où
je faisais tout ce qu'ils avaient à
faire tandis que me lie à
l'expropriation alors forcément j'ai
perdu pas mal écrit à jamais perdus au
camp du passeur j'avais perdu là aussi
la zone euro qui a coûté toi là où 31
alors je les perdrais pas mal mes
clients n'avaient à ce qu'ils sont
partis à chennevières j'en avais ici la
maison d'église top 10 j'en avais au 26
900 avait sur la rue des maronites
existe plus tout le monde est parti
abbas commencer par auch descendait le
matin je commençait à couler monde quels
enjeux crush pétrissez ma première
fournée et puis alors le temps que ma
première fournée que cuisait jal élabore
et puis je faisais mais croissant
j'augmentais depuis ce but 20 petits
cafés jeu j'attaquais ma première
fournée de façon à ce qu'ils sortent à 6
heures du matin là les vagues et là
encore les baguettes et si le betar
bricole back up et le début ils ont
commencé par par boucher le pansage
expropriés tulou du passage qui avaient
des petits pavillons
alors ils ont commencé par évacuer tout
son monde comme ils ont été éparpillés
un petit peu dans tous les coins
mais plus rien sur chaque machine on a
fermé on a fermé la boutique et puis ma
femme allait temps imparti faille chez
moi je fais le taxi et votre âme que ce
qu'elle fait à l'évent 2 hamon offrit la
rue de ménilmontant est alors comment
comment vous êtes comment vous avez
supporté le choc
bah c'est difficilement il a bien fallu
le supporter mon sens ça a été assez
difficile à supporter très difficile et
encore même main
on se demande toujours comment c'est que
ça va se passer on se demande comment ça
va se passer
alors on a toujours comme une peur on a
toujours la peur quand on entend frapper
on se demande qui que ces critiques il
vient fera
et s'il sait pas un fichier quelconque
pour une chose nous pourrions alors on
vise perpétuellement dans la peur
continuellement continuellement
continuellement ça faisait tellement de
bruit que les murs et les troubles
ma crainte ils ont démoli la côte et au
qu'avait j'avais un réveil du melon
passé tout coûte elle quand j'ai assez
joyeux ou entre les murs pratique sans
coût de sa ayissi s'était paré masqué en
dessous c'est et creux il y avait une
cave ou qui restent il y avait une cave
quand ça tremblait dans la cave
les émaux 10 au sol ou cassés
c'était pas c'est pas de la tarte
[Musique]
ça peut s'écrouler d'un moment à l'autre
parce qu'il paraît que le mur qui est
prêt à tomber là c'est le mur qui
soutient la maison alors s'ils tombent
qu'est ce qui va se passer on va se
retrouver en dessous j'en ai encore
causer dernièrement avec un monsieur des
hlm qui est venu il m'a répondu qu'est
ce que vous voulez tant que votre
propriétaire n'a pas vendu on peut rien
faire pour d'autres les affaires sont
joyeusement mené les meubles ne rompt
pas un long trajet à faire pour se
retrouver dans le nouvel immeuble d'un
côté s'adressant enfin ça c'était les
quelque chose sacrée
c'était quelque chose de sacré nous y
sommes arrivés à rester dans le coin
parce que d'une part nous avions formé
une petite amicale des locataires on a
fait voir que malgré tout notre coin 7
c'est très con ne voulais pas partir de
là on était fermement
convaincu qu'on pouvait nous reloger là
bas et en haut mais combien de logements
et enfin
[Musique]
on arrivait quand même avoir nos
logements l'album est dans l'ensemble
très content aussi pour mes boulots
malheur alors à leur malheur je pense
bien je pense bien quand on pense qu'on
a pu vivre dans ces taudis comme ça
alors ça fait drôle maintenant je prends
moi la première fois je suis monté ici j
me pas possible je pense chez moi là
c'est trop bien c'est trop beau quoi on
oui c'est bien mais c'est cher
[Musique]
il conduit ni les pays
et puis le chauffage en plus c'est
magnifique jean pagé progressé en parts
aux filles mais quand même
se posant des raisons les vieux je vois
comment qu'ils font mais c'est bien que
je pourrais pas payer 8000 ils sont là
depuis deux ans et 30 ans avait il
trouverait il trouve seulement c'est une
horreur c'est trop cher
ils sont obligés de partir quand même
parce que quand ils ont commencé à
démolir savait son cette partie là parce
que kiss cool et on est habitués on a
tous nos habitudes nous ici ça fait je
vous dis ça fait 22 ans qu'on est là on
n'a ni on a nos habitudes on peut on
peut pas se faire d autres habitudes
ailleurs où on ne connaît pas c'est pas
possible on a nos amis on a nos familles
on a c'est dur moi je sais que s'il
fallait vraiment j'aille en banlieue et
ben je me plairait pas non mon père
habitait dans le quartier avant au
pansage ega lacroix un peu plus fort
puis mes parties abri
pourquoi pas chaussé démoli ouais et
puis l'allemand les en échange ici puis
ont donné était content d'être revenu
bas ou carrément comment tu vivais là
bas je suis allé à l'école je rentrais
chez moi c'était tout plein chantait pas
que les copains mais c'était pas pareil
ici c'était pas les mêmes copains non
pourquoi des amis d'enfance ici bah oui
j'avais 16 ans je suis dans le quartier
saison j'ai connu du toit si je pars et
ses 18 ans je suis un quartier qui n'ont
aucune compassion sont le fait de partir
les copines et copains on allait dans
les maisons on trouvait des choses dont
16 une cabale un jour l'autre mais l'aja
ne voyait plus les i on s'ennuyait
on compte 58 zaza folies et pitié
rumeurs après d'angra hlm et ben
scientifique
ça change des produits tout ça alors je
vais goûter à mon réseau
[Musique]
que faire pour que belleville ne meurt
pas mais simplement se transforme donc
ne soit pas briser tous les liens tissés
par le temps pour que son histoire ne
s'arrête pas là pour que de nouvelles
amours de nouvelles amitiés puis il
continue et les anciennes jacquet
blanche avait vu le grand immeuble s'est
levé au fond de leur passage
il se demandait avec inquiétude et y
aura-t-il une place pour nous
ils y sont aujourd'hui mais beaucoup de
leurs amis sont absents beaucoup
d'autres sur le point de partir
voudrais vous demander un petit service
vous avez un aspirateur vous pourrez me
le préfet majeur des régions merci l'ami
charge un peu aussi va de notre côté
l'avant voyez que bâle faut oui ça
change un peu
c'est du tout au tout allawi avait m qui
peut demander c'est un petit coin pour
que les gaspille jouer bas rip wii party
sont pas adaptés à mon enfant soleil
ah oui oui j'espère parce que les gosses
à il leur en faut de l'espace quand même
hein les fleurs c'est joli oh oui c'est
ça oui que les pleurs c'est bien joli
ils me font penser aussi aux vins
par la mémoire de ces enfants belleville
vieux quartier soudain très jeune
pourra-t-il renouer le fil de son
histoire
non
[Musique]